[Music]
this past weekend if you visited ninjas
now dormant twitch channel it was
redirecting you to some of his biggest
competitors and particularly on Sunday
things got a little awkward when one of
those channels were to streaming porn so
if you're a ninja fan but have been
living under a rock the last little
while he left twitch for mixer about a
week and a half ago mixer is more or
less the same thing as twitch but owned
by Microsoft the way that this worked
was mixer basically went in and bought
ninja from twitch if you're looking for
more information on that we did an
entire video on it so naturally to us
and many in the gaming world this all
seemed like a shock I obviously can't
speak to whether or not twitch knew
anything about ninja living but losing
your biggest streamer can't feel good
and of course we saw that as they remove
this check mark like five minutes after
he made the announcement to which
basically all of Twitter said that was
the fastest which had ever responded to
anything so just a few days after the
move twitch started using ninjas old
channel twitch.tv vac sauce ninja as a
landing page that redirected you to the
other top fortnight channels so after
all of that the dust kind of settled
Ninja was still streaming to tens of
thousands of people on mixer and twitch
was using its page this way that is
until Sunday where the top channel
twitch was recommending on ninjas page
was showing porn and of course this
prompted an immediate response from
ninja and they were still using my
channel to promote other streamers well
now there was a porn account that was
number one being recommended on my
channel and I have no say in any of this
stuff so here's what happened some
Russian channel categorized under
fortnight was streaming porn for hours
to 14000 viewers and that was being
shown as a recommended Channel two
ninjas viewers ninjas old viewers coming
to see where he'd gone after the last
week in half now as shocking as this all
sounds if you are anywhere near twitch
on a regular basis you know
this is not the first time porn has been
broadcast at tens of thousands of people
the reality is twitch can't control it
broadcasters can put whatever they want
on their screen and then it's up to
twitch to act quickly and shut it down
as quickly as possible but what's crazy
about porn on Twitch this time is that
it was being broadcast as a recommended
channel for one of their most followed
streamers for hours before anything was
done about and once it was finally
taking down twitch a CEO took to Twitter
to apologize to ninja and revert his
channel back to normal so here's what
Twitter CEO Emmett shear had to say our
community comes to twitch looking for
live content to help ensure they find
great live channels we've been
experimenting with showing recommended
content across Twitch including on
streamers pages that are offline which
of course they did with ninja this helps
all streamers as it creates new
community connections however the lewd
content that peered on ninjas offline
channel page grossly violates our Terms
of Service and we've permanently
suspended the account in question on a
more personal note I want to apologize
directly to ninja that this happened it
wasn't our intent but it should have not
happened no excuses
so after this exchange took place on
Twitter between the CEO and ninja ninja
Shanna was then reverted back to its
normal state with no recommendations now
of course with anything viral like this
there's gonna be a lot of takes on the
Internet and for me it all comes back to
one simple question who owns the viewers
on ninjas channel him or twitch and at
first glance it seems obvious twitches
of this massive company they're a
subsidiary of Amazon one of the world's
largest corporations they should be able
to advertise on their platform however
they want but as you know when it comes
to twitch and streamers and this kind of
world that we've all caught ourselves in
it's not as simple as that
streaming and content creation and
gaming it kind of feels like this DIY
homegrown world these guys are you know
going out every single day streaming for
eight hours two handfuls of viewers
until their community rises up and grows
and is able to jam
we move their career forward so whether
it's artificial or not they're kind of
always feels like this partnership and
twitch even uses that word itself that
we hang on to as viewers and fans of the
platform so what so you see what I don't
like about that's what you're doing that
is if you look at other streamers that
went to mixer from twitch that were
partnered like look at Renee for example
you could go to Renee's stream it's
totally fine she's hosting people it's
totally normal and it's right there that
I think is the cause of people yelling
at each other on Twitter about this on
one side you have the people that are
upset that twitch broke this kind of
social contract on a twitch page it
feels like every decision is made in
partnership but this time to exchange a
ninja's page without even talking to
them and then on the other side you have
a world full of people that think you
know this is a massive company they can
do whatever the [ __ ] they want with
their platform but to me with all this
kept in mind it feels a little cheap to
go under ninjas page and alter it in a
way that he has no idea about after a
couple years of him being a massive
presence that brought tons of eyes to
your platform but on the other side of
this equation and then just not still
that sort of homegrown DIY guy that we
described when we think of twitch
streamer he's trying to grow his brand
into a massive entity just like Amazon
or Microsoft we saw that this weekend
when he gave out this phone number to
all of his fans so that they could text
him and communicate with him so I'm
giving you guys my number you ready it
is three one two five eight four four
six eight four send me a text message
right now there's gonna be a link that's
gonna follow fill it out so I have your
information and I'm gonna be able to
contact you guys text you guys
personally send you guys awesome videos
messages behind the scenes of whatever
event that my beautiful wife Jess and I
are at or even freaking cute adorable
pictures of our little puppies who are
just laying on the couch right now but
at the end of the day it's not like his
PR company or his agency isn't gonna use
that data to further grow his brand that
harmless little phone number that you
gave
ninja now so you can communicate with
one of your favorite streamers can be
used for a number of different
information gathering efforts people
working for a ninja's brand or some
marketing organization out there can use
that information to figure out your age
your location your gender and I'm not
I'm not trying to say that ninja is evil
but all of that is on the table map all
that information it's out there and this
kind of brings me full circle back to my
point from the last video this deal with
mixer is groundbreaking in that it kind
of removes a lot of ninjas worries about
stuff like this on mixer he's being paid
a salary he's not losing sleep over his
viewership or porn or whatever kind of
crazy [ __ ] this IRL section of twitch is
doing right now so this is the world
that we live in now you know we've cut
porn on Twitch and ninjas bigger than
professional athletes somehow and people
are IRL streaming their Disneyland trips
and all we can really do is sit back and
watch what happens next and then do it
don't ask me about it thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]